new motivation watch a top ten with
believe nation
Oh
he's got woke up all das and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
volume 6 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one choose the right kind of pain have
any of you tried doing exercise like a
gym workout or jogging and have realized
but physically activity is painful have
any of you as school or college students
worked hard to get good grades and have
realized that studying hard is ladies
and gentleman pain is such an integral
part of life but try as hard as we make
it just cannot escape but we have a
choice to accept the right country that
initially hurts but eventually needs
that initially is uncomfortable but
eventually unleashes our true potential
but initially we want to avoid but
eventually very happily accept or the
wrong kind of pain where the beginning
is so much pleasure but at the end
life is just a deal where in the
beginning you so mesmerised but at the
end just a royal mess where in the
beginning things are so comfortable but
at the end endlessly
complex the pain of exercise or the pain
of disease which one will you choose
rule number two live your life my soccer
team are Nicky but when will you release
your life after death in school you are
struggling to get to ten in ten girls
ready to get fit well luckily to get on
that mission after admission is
struggling to get a job after girl job
is struggling to get a wife or husband
after I got a wife or husband is for
need to give them up can you believe
that map quake bad but on each travel
kirti kirti I'm not even gene ID
yeah I'm just reminded of a very popular
Bollywood song that I heard all the time
in our child was one of the most popular
number Amaury radio pay but star Atacama
I can never forget the two lines of the
song ice age even behave Joji
jankoji me severely more god food ASAP
jokey maybe Jake okay miss the baby
physic
[Music]
more business emoji
your day isn't what to chill don't live
the life of a corpse just dragging
yourself from one stage of stage of life
to another stage of life from 10 to 12
from 12 to engineering from engineering
to post graduation post graduate to the
work from work to bills to marriage to
pay the bills to pay the income taxes to
pay the feast begin Nichols IV
pathologically Gina will give up capital
imaginable here moving from one place to
another in my life I just forgot to live
my life remember three don't give up
life is exactly like a game why should
we be discouraged when we have the
support of meaningful friends and family
why should we be discouraged when there
are powers higher than us to help us why
should we be discouraged when there's
still life left why should we be
discouraged when the final whistle has
not been blown yet the truth is that
many of us blow the final whistle
ourselves by giving up but as long as
there is life nothing is impossible and
it's never too late next time you feel
discouraged just remember that the final
whistle is not blown yet and you can
still give your best never give up and
you will soon reach there
remember for walk your own path I have a
five men who got lost in a washed forest
and we're trying to find their way out
the first man said I'm going to follow
my intuition and go to the left the
second man said I'm going to go right I
have a strong feeling that that's the
way out the third man said well I'm
going to walk back on the same path that
we took to reach here I think that would
be the safest the fourth man said I
think we are absolutely on the right
track already and so I'm going to keep
walking straight after the four men took
to the left the right back and straight
respectively the fifth man said well I
don't know what to do I think I'm just
going to climb up the store tree and get
a better view or nah before I make up my
mind from the top of the tree the fifth
man could now see what was the shortest
way to the village isn't it a fact that
when you rise above a situation and see
the larger picture your decision seems
to be the most sound well yes indeed
there's a slight twist to the story the
fifth man thought that the others should
not have chosen the paths they did and
that he was right and they were wrong
and from one point of view he was right
but from another perspective I'm not too
sure each man had chosen his own path
and gained a different experience it's
not just about right or wrong but about
gaining your own experience and finding
your own path the man who went left
found a long path but at the end well it
led him to the town the man who went
right at the white a pack of wolves
but then he learned how to survive in
the forest the man who went backwards
met another team of hikers and guess wha
he made new friends the man who went
straight found a farm and was hosted by
the family for a couple of days before
leaving for the village and of course
the man on the tree found the shortest
path the journey enriched each one of
them in their own unique way
every decision offers us new experiences
which in turn adds to our maturity
understood ultimately leading to our own
growth is an asset but life is like an
exam people fail because it tried to
copy others not realizing that each one
has a different question paper a
different test
ladies and gentlemen walk your own path
while you also learn from the experience
of others also if you want to learn how
to have more confidence check out my 250
for confidence series it's free the link
is in the description below it's easy to
make a buck very hard to make a
difference remember 5 shift your focus
in a certain company a young employee
who went to the HR head and said I can't
work here any longer I want to quit this
job the HR head asked why please tell me
what happened the whole atmosphere is so
toxic to my mind replied the young man
there are people here who are into a lot
of politics then there are those who
talk negative all the time some spent
most of their time gossiping then
working I don't think I can handle this
any longer the HR head said okay but I
have a request to make before you leave
the man asked please tell me what can I
do for yourself but HR head said I want
you to do this one last thing sincerely
I want you to take a glass of water
filled to the brim and walk around the
office area three times without spilling
a single drop of water on the floor
after that you may leave the job if you
wish to it sounded weird the man thought
it was just a matter of few minutes
anyways we took a glass full of water
and walked three times around the office
floor he men came to the HR head to tell
him what he was done the HR had asked
when you were walking around the office
floor did you see any employee speaking
badly about another employee any gossips
any disturbances the man replied no the
HR head further asked did you see any
employee looking at another employee in
a wrong way
no replied the young man and you know
why as the HR head because you were
focused on the glass to make sure you
didn't tip over and spill any water and
the same goes with our life when we
focus on our priorities we don't have
the time to see all the drama around us
the mistakes of others gossip politics
negativity etc the fact is anywhere we
go we are going to find toxic people
change of job a change of situation
doesn't necessarily ensure freedom from
such people we should certainly do what
we can to positively change things
around us but when we know that we've
done our best and things still remain
more or less the same we should shift
our focus to the glass of water our
priorities our growth our excellence
we won't be as much affected by the
negativity around us rule number six
change your perspective a man once
called for his four sons and sent each
of them to go and have a look at a pear
tree that was a distance away from their
home at their own convenience the first
son went to look at the tree in the
winter season the second in the spring
the third in summer and the youngest son
went to look at the tree in the fall
after a year had passed by the father
asked all four of them if they had
visited the tree and if they could
describe to him what they had seen the
first son said the tree was oddly bent
and twisted
the second son said are you kidding the
tree was covered with fresh green buds
and seemed so promising disagreeing with
his two brothers the third son said it
was full of blossoms that smelled so
sweet and looked so gracious it is the
most beautiful thing I have ever seen in
my life the last son said they're all
wrong dad the tree was survived
I'm trooping with fruit it was so full
of life the man explained to his sons
that they were all correct because each
one of them had seen only one season in
the life of the tree and then he taught
them a very important lesson that you
cannot charge a tree or a person by only
one season by only one phase of their
life the sense of who they are can only
be measured at the end when all the
seasons are up if you give up when it's
winter you'll miss the promise of your
spring the beauty of your summer
and the fulfillment of your form let's
not allow the pain of one season to
destroy the joy of the rest
let's not incharge life by one difficult
season let's endure the difficult times
with the hope and better times are sure
to come sooner or later remember seven
except making mistakes possibly we could
be making serious mistakes in our life
especially in the zeal of youth in the
SuperDuper enthusiasm Z energy as young
men and ladies indeed we could be making
some serious mistakes but what's
beautiful in life is life allows us to
correct those mistakes and pencil PP
chakra Bharata rebuttable Tatum looks
boom arribada and the first time we got
this pencil with a rubber in a razor
behind it's nice
because mistakes can be erased some
mistakes we have made can be corrected
some mistakes we can't the consequences
are so bad we just have to now have the
support system to handle a many mistakes
can't even be reversible sometimes isn't
it
you see Liam can you bark at a Hindi
methane Kiba Volker Nana broccoli PA
somehow I have not as a quarry had your
bullying Carver manly naina Sanskriti a
its culture to accept that I made a
mistake I look to mistake mantini
they don't accept a made a mistake bull
karna prakruti a man lena
sans creepy hair or su Darlena pragati a
progressive life is to accept that I
made a mistake and to try and not repeat
it again and improve in the area that we
made a mistake rumor 8 open your eyes
isn't it true that our birth is given to
us by others a name given by others
education given by others resources to
live hiya palace given by others income
earned by us but given by others love
and respect given by others even our
last rites are performed by others after
death all our positions will either be
taken away by others or will go to
others don't you think it's vanity to
think that it's all done by me and it's
all about me certainly we do have our
role in what we've done and
cheap yet when we start being conscious
of the fact that so many have done and
are doing so much for us we start living
in awareness we experience humility we
feel grateful and it isn't that state
mind but we start dealing with others
with great sensitivity love and respect
shifting our focus and attention from
just renewing it all to many others
contributing so much to our life can
indeed transform the quality of our
relationships won't lie to comes so much
more meaningful if we close our eyes and
open our eyes to see what others have
done for us rule number nine serve a
beautiful or wealthy lady all she
dressed went to happiness counselor and
complain but she felt that her life was
empty and had no meaning the counselor
patiently heard her out and then called
over the old lady who claimed the office
floors the counselor then said to the
rich lady I'm going to ask this old lady
to tell us how she found her happiness
and let's listen to her for the old lady
put down her broom sat on a chair and
started telling her story within a short
span of three months
I lost my husband who died of malaria
and my only son who was killed in a car
accident life became meaningless but
nobody and nothing left I couldn't sleep
I couldn't eat I
for God thoughts my in fact
total and in my life
and one evening as I returned from work
Kidman followed me home I felt really
sorry a little what this was cold
outside I decided to let the kitten in I
got some milk had the kitten licking the
plate hey Bennett pearled and rubbed
against my leg and for the very first
time in months I smiled I wondered to
myself if helping a little kitten could
make me smile maybe doing something for
people in me could it make me happy so
the next day I baked some biscuits and
took them to a neighbor who was sick and
was in this every single day I tried to
do something good for someone so happy
to see them happy today I do not know of
someone who sleeps and eats better when
I do found my happiness by giving it and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is focus on
growing yourself when I was in school a
friend of mine borrowed my notebook to
catch up with some of the classes he had
missed and not to my knowledge
copied one of the essays that I had
written he then used it for an essay
competition which he ended up winning
when I got to know I feel cheated I was
very upset and felt that this was sheer
stealing another time a PhD student told
me that her professor took her research
paper and published it in his name
people working in the corporate world
have told me that they found the reports
bill Boreas Lea made stolen by their
colleagues their personal game authors
have often complained of plagiarism as
well
and surely whichever area of work it may
be we shall deal with people who have
such a corrupt distorted mindset at the
same time we should also remember that
what we possess is way beyond an essay
way beyond a research paper or a report
a bird once asked a honeybee you work so
hard you toy so much you put so much
effort and energy to make and store
honey and
the man comes and steals it do not be
sad the honeybee gave a fantastic reply
yes I do feel sad at that moment but
then I remind myself that the only thing
a man can steal from me is my honey he
can never steal the art of making honey
that I possess again we certainly need
to deal with such cheating in a
practical way we also need to be aware
the people can the best copy or creation
not a creativity we can invest in our
technique not our talent they can
imitate what we do but cannot take away
our ability to inspire which is why I
say focus on and grow that which no one
can steal and let everything else simply
be a manifest of it now I've got a
special bonus clip from guru Gopal das
on how to find your inner drive that I
really think you could enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go number one where do you need to
most focus on growing yourself number
two how can you better serve somebody
this week and number three where do you
need to just accept making mistakes
iberic but just schools in North Korea
or Steve lemarchal picture the Buick
HGTV the manager timidly
Sabatini masa puja GT mechanic i'ma man
amber Jessica Peter eternity Malachi
Madame up capito bachata with demand
America's as a co-teacher NATO eatin a
pretty bow on the cheek upon her by
better work ERP skip projection TV
avasta Callie or curry bar so bad
Jamar kadhi hunt over Y but cha-cha a
big bot mature beggining Panjagutta
market Antonin Scalia
sorry video que por una kepis chad began
Achmat eye-opening mark agave or my
table controller mikuni sorrow for an
objective minute jesse was driving in
Caracas a Subin gentlemanly cutter madam
of capito ich number couple to a famous
a cyclical tom notch okay a misses
school say Nicole Grey theater hoga er s
a car piensa que la cosa better assume
kaput segue veganic Maldini gtk me
Chilika Jehan thomas edison a bow to
bachata g SE ischaemic a vishwas Horsa
martin a Etna barovik amoeba Naya
diversity no Harvey ACTA Mukasey vicious
yoga da cunha kha pu che mi vishwas
carnival equally Act II marches key word
pili Mel Jana - Peter ki AAG barnacle PA
or visual kalyana mata boondi
kisi se reacting to atma vishwas scary
yeah bunny boomer chilli your kiss again
peter chippy was our co
that guy
if you want more Google copal - check
out the top 50 rules video made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there you will
have to make one choice you're not going
to be spared by life you will always
have to make one choice